>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN JORDAN,
THANK YOU.
FURTHERMORE, LET'S BRING IN
BRETT PULLMAN, FORMER U.S.
ATTORNEY.
AND HARRY LITMAN, DEPUTY
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL
DURING THE BILL CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
BRETT, YOUR VIEW OF THE DOCUMENT
PRODUCTION.
YOU HEARD WHAT CONGRESSMAN
JORDAN SAID.
PALPABLE FRUSTRATION WITH THE
THWARTING OF WHAT THE G.O.P.
MAJORITY BELIEVES IS THE
RIGHTFUL OVERSIGHT ROLE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH OVER THIS
PROCESS THAT LED TO THE SPYING
ON AN AMERICAN CITIZEN THROUGH
THE USE OF THIS FISA COURT.
>> IT'S INTERESTING TO HEAR
REPRESENTATIVE JORDAN BECAUSE HE
IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
THEY HAVE OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY.
I HAVE THE LUXURY OF WORKING IN
THE SENATE PRIOR TO BECOMING THE
U.S. ATTORNEY.
DURING THAT FOUR YEAR PERIOD
DURING THAT FOUR YEAR PERIOD   P
DURING THAT FOUR YEAR PERIOD   R
DURING THAT FOUR YEAR PERIOD   O
DURING THAT FOUR YEAR PERIOD
DURING THAT FOUR YEAR PERIOD   F
TIME, I HEARD THE DEMOCRATS
ASKING AGAIN AND AGAIN FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO BE
TRANSPARENT.
GIVE US DOCUMENTS.
IT'S IRONIC FOR ME TO SEE THEM
SAYING HOLD UP.
THIS IS NOT THEIR PREROGATIVE.
THEY ARE GOING TOO FAR.
NO.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
LONG HELD CONGRESS WITH SOME
DISDAIN AND HAS TREATED THEM AS
A STEP BROTHER OR SISTER, NOT
WORRYING ABOUT WHAT THEY WANT
AND NOT ANSWERING THEIR
SUBPOENAS OR REQUESTS FOR
DOCUMENTS.
I SAW IT FRONT AND CENTER.
>> Laura: I THINK THE
DEMOCRATS WERE THE PARTY THAT
WAS GOING TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE
AGAINST GOVERNMENT OVERREACH.
THE GOVERNMENT INTEL, THEY ARE
GOING TO BE SPYING ON AMERICANS.
IT'S A HEAVY FOOT.
WE DON'T TRUST IT.
WE DON'T TRUST THE BIG
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE
RIGHTS.
NOW YOU HAVE THE DEMOCRATS
SEEMING TO GIVE CARTE BLANCHE TO
THE FISA COURT AND THE WAY IT
OPERATED WITH THIS APPLICATION
FOR THE WARRANT AND SO FORTH.
THIS IS LEGITIMATE FOR CONGRESS